i'm steve ducey i'm dana parino i'm
tyrus
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday june 30th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
what is critical race theory and why is
it prompting such visceral reaction
around the country
especially in schools it's an argument
that says
all black problems today are the fault
of whites
and the responsibility of whites to
solve still others feel
very differently this is something that
scholars have used
to understand how race is affecting
all of our systems in this country i'm
dave anthony
former president trump goes to the
border today in an area of texas overrun
in a surge of migrants that's been
tough to stop what they're dealing with
right now because it's such a large
influx
is they think they have a handle on
things in one area
and then you know word will spread that
they're in that area
and then it gets overwhelming in another
area of the border
and i'm geraldo rivera i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
it's prompted loud raucous school board
meetings like this one
in loudoun county virginia
[Applause]
my child is not oppressed and don't
assume that
as long as you marxist push your
unconstitutional agenda
on my child she will not be returning
back to mountain county school
recall efforts against school board
members have greatly increased parent
groups have formed and educators are on
defense
asking what are we allowed to say as
some states push for and pass
new laws banning crt from being taught
in schools
critical race theory it's gone beyond
concerns about k-12 education
and sparked debate with top military
brass i do think it's important
actually for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
and i want to understand white rage and
i'm white and i want to understand it
general mark milley testified during a
recent house committee hearing
i've read miles seyton i've read i've
read karl marx
i've read lenin that doesn't make me a
communist so what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we
are here to defend and i personally find
it offensive
that we are accusing the united states
military our general officers
are commissioned non-commissioned
officers of being quote woke
or something else because we're studying
some theories that are out there for all
the anger and talk about what crt
is most school boards insist their new
equity programs or attempts to support
black and brown students
are not curriculum changes that result
in the teaching of this theory
so what is it i'll read what the
american bar association has put out
about this in january
they first note that when he was
president donald trump issued an
executive order
that banned from federal contracts any
divisive concepts about race or sex
stereotyping or scapegoating
president biden rescinded this order the
aba explains that crt critiques how the
social construction of race
and institutionalized racism perpetuates
a
racial caste system that relegates
people of color to the bottom tiers
they add that it acknowledges the legacy
of slavery
segregation and the imposition of
second-class citizenship on black
americans and other people of color
continues to permeate the social fabric
of this nation
crt or critical race theory in my mind
is an academic term crystal knight is a
democratic and social impact strategist
it's something that was developed in the
1980s
by legal scholars to really understand
how
race is framed in the systems of this
country
and how we should approach you know
thinking about
all of the systems and structures under
this particular lens
so i do not you know think that it is a
catch-all for social justice
for racial justice or any of those
things i look at it in the lens that
this is something that scholars have
used
to understand how race is affecting
all of our systems in this country and
when i hear people
push back against it what i'm hearing
them say is i don't want to talk about
race
which is you know something that they
should just say as opposed to
weaponizing this
ideology and making it something that
it's just simply not
so you're asking people to sort of
discuss debate everything
through that lens then that lens colors
everything when you say
everything what do you mean right and so
i think
if we're talking about you know race if
we're talking about a movement and we
say
based on the critical race theory
ideology or based on the critical race
theory
aspect this is how one could understand
how i would feel about racism being
prominent
in this system so specifically if i were
to say
america was founded you know with the
idea of
white male privilege being in mind and
looking at that from a critical race
theory perspective
a woman like me a black woman i was not
written in the the founding documents of
this of this country
if i'm looking at it through that lens
and so that's
that's a just an example of how we get
to understand
how critical race theory is woven in
or how we can think about race in all of
the context or a few of the
other contexts that we may dialogue
about or study
or whatever but again i don't think that
you know
this this assumption or this this you
know
question of are students being taught
this
actual ideology every single day in
schools
i reject that that thought and i reject
that that position
well i think one of the concerns is is
not that
necessarily crt is being taught but that
that lens is being applied
to like history class and while you have
like school boards saying well wait a
second our new equity or diversity or
inclusion program is not crt
you do have some educators talking in a
way that does alarm some parents and i
want to run this by you um
earlier this year there was a diversity
summit with an oregon school district
and i guess it was done virtually one
teacher said if you're not evolving into
an
anti-racist educator you'll become
obsolete
saying that teachers may even be fired
in the future for damaging and
traumatizing kids
by what she said is keeping up with the
old views of colonialism
and another teacher said that white
teachers need to be anti-racist with the
same zeal as the capital rioters on
january 6th
this is just you know one discussion
right when parents hear
that kind of language they get they get
afraid and they get skeptical that their
white children maybe are going to be
told you're an oppressor and that
children of color are the oppressed
when i hear um when i you know read the
article
and actually watch the video where she
was speaking
you know i i didn't i did not personally
take offense to it
um i i'm also i'm not a parent and i
don't have any
children in school actively so i have a
different perspective
you know black people in this country
and
any of anyone who identifies as
non-white
and i'm not speaking for an entire
population
of people but one thing that i believe
is true is that
history books in this country have been
written by white people
and when they're written by white people
they come with a white perspective
however you also have many teachers who
come from all different races and creeds
and so when you're taught in school
about the civil war for instance
in that you know the civil war was
fought because
this certain group of states wanted to
take back their land or
fight for their freedoms blah blah blah
blah blah
and as a black student sitting in a
class understanding that
the civil war was fought around keeping
black people enslaved
one has to imagine how are you you know
you say one one t one person will say
well i don't want critical race theory
taught in schools
but what about the black parents who say
well my my children
are not being taught the truth about the
civil war they're not being taught the
truth about
racial relation relations in this
country and so again
to just say that i don't want to talk
about race
in my school district and i'm going to
use critical race theory because of it
that's just
a false premise and we should just say
that and be honest
with our with our parents across this
country about that
now of course ask different folks what
crt is and why it's making some people
so upset and you'll get different
answers
jason reilly is a senior fellow at the
manhattan institute
a wall street journal columnist and a
fox news contributor
i think it's a fancy argument for racial
preferences
frankly i mean i think that's the
simplest way to
to understand it and and i'm not being
overly
reductive here if you go back to the
1970s
when uh these theories were coming out
of the legal community
in academia the argument put forward by
critical race theorists like derek bell
kimberly crenshaw and others was that
race should be used as an academic
credential in the hiring process in the
academy
that was their argument that's how they
wanted race used and they put forward
critical race theory as as the
justification
for that and that is um it's an argument
that says
all black problems today are the fault
of whites
and the responsibility of whites to
solve that
racism permeates all of our institutions
and has for
since slavery and before and therefore
that is the lens through which we should
judge
all racial disparities that we see today
this is the cause of them republicans
are passing
laws in some states to what to stop what
they
say is crt specifically in k-12
education
and i'm wondering some of these laws
don't even say the words critical race
theory necessarily
um like for example the tennessee bill
says educators can't talk about
systemic racism criticize meritocracy or
address
privilege or oppression um some
educators say this is
like stifling their speech uh like not
using the word oppression
where where do we where are we supposed
to go with some of these laws
and what they're telling teachers they
can say the way i sort of start
to think about this is that you know
your typical eighth grader in this
country and particularly in our largest
cities you know houston's in new york
and los angeles and chicago's
cannot read or do math at grade level i
mean
doesn't that strike you as a bigger
problem that we should be addressing
before we turn them into social justice
warriors
and particularly given that um
uh the kids who aren't uh reading and
doing math
at grade level are overwhelmingly black
and hispanic kids
the very groups that these progressives
claim to care the most about
and i i find it striking that that is
not their their main focus
uh instead um uh this the
centering as they say of race uh in
in in schools is is the focus and i i i
frankly can't think of a
more short-sighted or even dangerous
thing to do
than to take kids in an
increasingly pluralistic america you
know the fastest growing
groups are asians and and hispanics and
so forth
and teach these children to focus
on their racial and ethnic differences
i mean i i think that is that is
insanity
frankly jason i want to ask you because
it's not just
k-12 education right um recently
military brass got into it with
congressman matt gates at
a recent hearing um and they were
talking about if the military is
teaching
critical race theory and even they want
so far as to accuse the military of
hiring a critical race theorist to
advise on personnel matters
and defense secretary austin said and
i'm gonna quote i'm going to read this
quote
i don't know what the issue of critical
race theory is and what the relevance
here is with the department
we do not teach critical race theory we
don't embrace critical race theory
i think it's a spurious conversation
general milly said it was offensive to
suggest that members of the military
would be attempting to be quote woke by
merely reading about an academic theory
what is your thought on on the the
tension and discussion over
what the military is doing especially
because they they recently
have been investigating according to
secretary austin extremism within the
military
i don't think it's appropriate um i
don't think we should be doing it
but it tells you uh how far down this
road we've already gone
and how there is a need to push back uh
before we go
any further um this is a very divisive
concept it is playing one american
against another
um and and and that just will end it
will end badly
and and so um you know when when when
president trump um made an effort
to uh to stop this trend um
i think he was on the right track there
and uh
president biden seems intent on you know
doing the opposite of everything
that president trump did uh regardless
of of the merits of what the
the former president was doing but in
some cases
donald trump had it right and and uh i
think this is one of them
jason reilly fox news contributor wall
street journal uh
columnist and senior fellow at the
manhattan institute thank you so much
for your time
thank you
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary
coming up former president trump goes to
texas today
there is no more dire threat today than
the crisis
on our southern border saying at his
weekend rally in ohio
just a few short months ago drugs were
way down
human trafficking was way down it was
all way down
now after four months in a row of a
hundred thousand plus migrants being
apprehended
he blames president biden undoing some
trump border policies which
the new administration says were
inhumane vice president harris went to
texas last friday
welcome to el paso welcome to my
community
to the new ellis island to the capital
of the border
democratic congresswoman veronica
escobar greeted harris who republicans
demanded for months go to the border
then were critical she avoided areas
where the migrant surge is most intense
for the vice president counters
it is here in el paso that the previous
administration's
child separation policy was unveiled
and el paso where the return to mexico
policy from the previous administration
was implemented and harris insists we
must address the root causes of why they
come
we're talking about stories that involve
horrendous
tales of abuse
and fear and harm a former president
trump will be joined
by republican governor greg abbott in
westlake near
mcallen these are the areas that
republicans especially have said and
the numbers prove it these are the high
traffic areas
we caught up with fox business network's
grady trimble in la jolla texas outside
mcallen
when the vice president visited last
week they felt like
she didn't go to the right areas because
she didn't go to
the rio grande valley where migrants are
moving through here
so they've been critical of that and i
don't think it's an accident that
they're coming to this area they're
doing it intentionally because
this is where so many of the problems
are right now
so you're down there what have you seen
so far we were reporting live along the
border wall and it's interesting to see
in this area because
this is uh one of the areas where
construction was halted by the bina
administration so you can see areas
where the walls constructed
and then you can see areas where
obviously there were plans for wall
and and it's not there at all and then
after that we headed over
that was near mission texas we headed
over to la jolla which is about 20
minutes down the road
and this is one of the areas where we
are now where a lot of migrants and
families have been moving through
and that's exactly what we saw this
morning about
two dozen or so maybe more including
women
children and they were essentially
corralled by border patrol loaded into
buses
and presumably from there they go to the
processing facilities elsewhere
all right now describe the terrain
because
nobody can see anything where you are
right now what's it like
at the exact border spot where they're
coming across
so it's we are i would say a half a mile
to a mile
from the actual border this is an area
where if we
went through to the actual border and to
the rio grande river
uh we would have to go through very
dense brush
we would have to go over private
property uh and
eventually we would make it to the where
the the actual border is
so by the time they get to this area
they've gone through
all of that and that's when they
encounter border patrol potentially for
the first time
on the ground but there are of course
coast guard and other agencies border
patrol
on the river going up and down the river
and they're also
uh circling in helicopters and trying to
survey by
air to see these groups of migrants move
through this area
and then the ground crews meet them
where we are right now
do most try to cross the river at night
i was talking with the texas department
of public safety today and they're
essentially down here to assist
border patrol because border patrol is
so overwhelmed
with processing so they need help on the
border itself
and i asked that question as well and
they said it depends on the weather
it depends on the types of groups
whether
it's you know people with young kids
whether it's
people who appear to be members of
cartels
or smugglers um so you will see people
uh traveling in the early morning hours
just before the sun comes up
but when we saw that group of a couple
dozen people
it was broad daylight it was probably
nine in the morning
did any of them run did they were they
just walking together and then they were
just apprehended
what happened so my understanding is
actually that some of them
want to be apprehended because then
they're in the united states and sent to
a processing facility in the united
states and
you know it's it's as crazy as it sounds
a bit of respite after such a
treacherous journey that's the families
and the people who are
you know coming here from central
america on the flip side you have
people who are from mexico in fact griff
jenkins who's also down here with us
captured video of about five men who who
identified themselves
to him as people who were from mexico
they weren't with one of these groups of
women and children and families
and they did try to run from border
patrol so you have
both uh going on at the same time and
you know
border patrol and the other agencies
that are down here
are you know are constantly dealing with
with both of those
things those who are apprehended do they
all stay do some get sent back
i think some get sent back but honestly
when when we're talking to the
people on the ground near the border
they don't really know what
happens once they're loaded up into the
buses and taken to
the processing facility so they're not
as familiar with that
side of things what they are very
familiar with
is them actually being apprehended and
you know looking at the numbers
it is staggering just in the rio grande
valley where we are
2100 apprehensions in the last 24 hours
that doesn't even include the other
stretches of the southern border
elsewhere in texas and elsewhere in the
country
so those numbers are staggering and
that's what they're dealing with on the
ground here not necessarily the
processing side
um which is you know in a totally
different area
something else i know that you are
looking into while you're
at the border while you're reporting on
all this is
the drug smuggling and that's a big part
of the story at the border as well
it is and you can't even separate the
two
parts of this which is people coming
across the border and drugs coming
across the border because when we talk
to uh people on the ground here in law
enforcement
they tell us you know we're seeing tens
of thousands of pounds of drugs come
through
in a month's time and oftentimes the
cartels
are the ones leading the migrants
through here and they're getting paid to
do that
by the the migrants who are you know
seeking a better life here
but the the law enforcement that we've
talked to say
that's a problem because they're
literally receiving millions of dollars
to do this
and it's making the cartels more and
more powerful
and more and more dangerous in fact one
of the things we're following is
operation lone star
and that is essentially uh commissioned
by the governor in texas greg
abbott who said you know border patrol
so overwhelmed we're going to send some
of our people with the department of
public safety
to get involved as well and they found
over a million dollars in cash 140
firearms
again you know thousands of pounds of
illegal drugs
in uh just the few months that that
operation has been going on
right and we're talking about a variety
of drugs coming across right
oh yeah there's there's marijuana
there's cocaine and methamphetamine
those are the two largest categories of
types of drugs brought across
but there's also fentanyl too and as you
know
a lot of people across the country will
know that's extremely dangerous
and one of the reasons the you know
opioid epidemic has taken its toll on
people
in this country when you talk to a
border agent i know you did a short time
before we
we had our conversation do you feel
like they're overwhelmed or do they feel
like they have a handle on it
what are they saying i i think they feel
overwhelmed
or else they wouldn't be asking for help
from other state agencies whether it's
the
public safety department here in texas
or agencies
uh as far away as nebraska and florida
being sent
in to help um i i think that any amount
of help they can receive
they would be grateful for and frankly
they told me outright
on air and behind the scenes that they
don't think that the federal government
is doing enough and by that they mean
the biden administration
they'll tell you that you know the the
construction of the border wall is
helpful
from their experiences because it allows
them to
sort of push people into a certain
direction of the border
and then focus their resources on those
areas but right now as i mentioned
you see these huge gaps in the wall and
there are areas where it's not
constructed at all
and that makes their jobs extremely
challenging
and one of the agents i was just talking
to said
what they're dealing with right now
because it's such a large influx
is they think they have a handle on
things in one area
and then you know word will spread that
they're in that area
and then it gets overwhelming in another
area of the border
obviously governor abbott is wanting to
restart
all that construction and he's
soliciting people to donate and all of
that how much of the construction that
was stopped
can he do and is he facing legal
challenges to that
i'm sure he will i don't know of any
specifically but
the problem that even the federal
government deals with in terms of border
wall construction
is that a lot of the border is on
private property so they have to get
permission from the property owners
to build there i do know that from the
cooperative property owners
who who want governor abbott and the
state of texas to continue
erecting the wall they've put up
temporary
fences essentially in in certain areas
to try to send the message you know that
we're
we're here we're we're going to stop you
if you if you try to get through
but as the trump administration learned
as well it is a challenge to
to construct the border wall but abbott
seems keen on doing it he's put aside
250 million dollars
in state funding to do it and as you
said i think in
in the first week of that crowdfunding
effort the state raised
something like 450 000 um
and since we're talking about costs the
operation
lone star that they have going on right
now is costing two and a half million
dollars per week uh
and that's primarily in you know
overtime for the
crews that they have down here that's
housing them
in this area bringing them in from
elsewhere and putting them up in hotels
so that's an expensive operation as well
the landowners and you referenced the
that you need
some permission for this border wall on
private property but there have been a
lot of land owners who have
have had enough i mean they've had their
their property overrun by people coming
across the border
right yeah and we you know talk with
people on
fox business and fox news all the time
who are landowners
ranchers business owners who deal with
it all the time and they see these large
groups coming through their property
you know one of the challenges may be
they might own the property close to the
border but that doesn't mean they own
the the property
right on the border or even if they do
you know that maybe there's just not a
as much activity
uh in in terms of construction because
they're focusing their efforts
on other areas at the moment but
certainly there are a lot of people
in this stretch of the border who you
know who have had enough of it
especially lately
because if you look at the numbers it's
a huge increase from
you know a year ago grady trimble fox
business network correspondent
at the border in la jolla texas great to
talk to you thanks so much for joining
us grady
thank you dave
[Music]
[Applause]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast
dive deeper than the headlines in the
party lines as i take on
american life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo
rivera what's on your mind i grew up in
and around new york's times square
they used to say that if you stand on
the corner of 42nd street and broadway
long enough
eventually you'll see everybody you ever
knew because
everybody visits times square my fox
office now is a block away
it is the crossroads of the world the
beating heart
of the great white way but it is also
the scene recently of a toddler getting
caught
in a crossfire of a wild shootout
between rival gangs
and earlier this week a u.s marine 21
year old samuel poulin being shot in the
back
in another wild shootout in times square
this time involving rival
illegal street vendors this high-profile
violence has finally awakened new york's
sleepy mayor de blasio
who says he is surging 50 additional
cops
to patrol the legendary neighborhood
this from the mayor who allowed his
police force
to be defunded a billion dollars
and an entire police academy class to be
cancelled
tom harris who's the head of the times
square alliance of business people
and community leaders says these latest
high-profile incidents of violence
are the result of policies that do not
focus on the enforcement
of lower level offenses like the rival
gangs of street vendors
and emboldened these policies do would
be criminals to carry weapons
eric adams the former police captain who
leads in the race for new york city
mayor
said quote the news of another shooting
in times square in broad daylight
is a chilling reminder of the rising
threat of gun violence across
our city and folks it's not just new
york
it's where you live from friday
afternoon through early monday morning
at least 77 people were shot in chicago
77 people shot seven fatally
where i live now in cleveland ohio in
the week since the start of the summer
june 21st
my mid-sized midwestern city has
suffered 37 people shot
three stabbed four killed if this
carnage was not mostly black on black
perhaps the country would care more
because activists only seem to care
if a cop is involved we are witnessing a
national ghetto civil war
fueled by drugs and gangs and guns
this is the civil rights issue of our
time
i'm herald or vera reporting fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes